hi i'm greg sadler i am a teacher of
philosophy currently teaching this year
at marist college
and i'm creating videos for my classes
at marist college but some of the videos
are i think more general interest or
could be of use to to other people
outside of my classroom so
i'm offering them on the internet and
this is one of them this video has to do
with
how to study a philosophical text
and i'm going to talk about four things
i'm going to talk about
the nature of
classic text or great books
and then some nuts and bolts some
techniques of reading
that can be used in order to dig further
and further into philosophical texts and
then i'm going to talk about how to
insert yourself or maybe even get
yourself invited if you want to think
about that that way to the the wider
context
to the broader conversations about about
these texts and these issues and these
thinkers
and all the things that come into play
with those and then finally i'm going to
leave you with a kind of caution but
also a bit of encouragement i'm going to
give some pointers that i think would be
of use to students
or people generally interested in in
culture in intellectual
works in in reading philosophical texts
so that doesn't have to be somebody
necessarily in school
it could be anybody who is interested in
reading the great works of philosophy
that we have handed down from century to
century to century
whether they're in school or not i think
these these pointers could be useful for
that and i'm going to preface this by
saying these are just pointers this is
stuff that's coming from my own
experience and reflecting on it
not necessarily
the be all and end all of how one has to
approach philosophical texts
what i'm going to say here is oriented
for my class for my class is
but it's also intended to
sort of steer people into a path of
lifelong learning
if if i can teach somebody plato
you know get them to read parts of the
republic or even just you know the
apology and get them to come away with
that and have some content that they
remember a year two years three years
later something that's impressed them
something that they've been able to use
in their life that's good but what i
really would like to
encourage and and give people the tools
for
and
maybe
in a certain way initiate them in i'm
getting
more
cognizant of this as i as i age as i
mature as a philosopher as i mature as a
professor
what i'd really like to do is get them
sort of started on a path
that they continue on to give them
resources to give them a sort of
direction drive
that they will then continue on with in
their own life and read plato on their
own or read aristotle on their own or
read nietzsche or whoever you want
descartes
even spinoza you know i'm not a big
spinoza fan but if if i can get you
reading spinoza and you'll continue that
for the rest of your life because you
find something of value there
that's great that's what i that's what i
want to do and i think that's what most
professors of philosophy want to do in
their classes
so
that's a good lead-in
for
some some
context if you want to put yourself in
the proper frame of mind to approach a
philosophical text i think it can be
helpful to think about
why we call certain works classics
if you think about that why are certain
books considered classics
and others just sort of fall by the
wayside uh after not not that long you
know
what may be the philosophical bestseller
at the time can turn out to be somebody
who's really
only available in dusty volumes on
shelves and a bunch of footnotes in
graduate students dissertations
um several generations later that's
happened to a lot of philosophers
there's other philosophers who we keep
going back to over and over and over
again who
you know if you want to think about this
in very commercial terms think about
bookstores you go into
a bookstore
and you see all of those classics think
about used bookstores those are a really
great example because you know what used
bookstores have all the books that
people are sort of cycling through and
recycling
you can find all these classics
in a lot of different editions and it's
not just because most of them are
public domain and so you can you know
publish them very cheaply
it's because they
they sell but
they
move
there's a difference between selling
and then moving
and you know being somebody bringing it
back and and
another person would being willing to
buy it again you know a lot of best
sellers
you people will buy them and then
they'll sell them to a used bookstore
and the used bookstore won't give very
much for them because they know that you
know a bestseller that's you know
three four years old is probably not
going to have stood the test of time
and be something that somebody else
really wants
but if you take plato's republic
or aristotle's nickel mccain ethics or
descartes meditations on philosophy
or you know
well kant you know
more of a specialized taste there if you
take any of these works
and you try to sell them back people
will buy them because they know somebody
will read these why well because these
are classics why are they classics
well
people have found them valuable
not the book itself of course
but the text the thoughts inside
people have found them valuable
and they found them valuable from
generation to generation to generation
within all these different contexts
they
many of them
translate well across cultures as a
matter of fact
many of the things that we consider
classics
are culturally
very very different from the culture
that we inhabit you know there's this
notion that there's this canon of
western literature
and you know it's it's being oppressive
to only read say saint augustine the
world that saint augustine lived in
is radically different than the world
that we live in
the world that plato lived in even more
different
even the world that thomas aquinas lived
in
or it picked somebody more recent even
the world that certain kierkegaard lived
in
very very different from from the
culture that we inhabit and that which
forms us and the way in which we
approach things
so you know we can learn a lot like
descartes said
um
reading books
can be sort of like a form of travel and
travel he saw as a great way of
expanding your horizons so people have
found these books valuable across
generations over and over again keep
that in mind when you approach a
philosophical text
when you're reading plato
you know try to read past you're
probably reading it in some sort of
stuffy translation
done by some oxford or cambridge types
years ago
look past that language and say to
yourself
at the beginning of your reading
you know other people have found a lot
of stuff here
other people thought that this was worth
their while to spend time on
um
to preserve to offer to others to teach
to others
to investigate to to write about
why do they do that well they find some
things in those books that are
captivating
or stimulating
they find some things that sometimes
that can orient their entire life or
their mindset
sometimes the the books are classics
because they in order to make them work
you have to work yourself so hard that
it it exercises your mind and it makes
you a better thinker
after you're done with it some of them
because they introduce us to new ways of
looking at things new horizons new
vistas
that's something to keep in mind i'll
give you a very short story here
one of the professors that i studied
plato with in the classics department
not in the philosophy department when i
was a graduate student
we read the symposium and we read it in
greek and the symposium is one of
plato's finest works as a matter of fact
if in greek it's one of the finest works
of western literature but by itself is a
philosophical work it's it's got a lot
of meat there and you can read it and
read it over and over again and he told
me i have been reading the symposium for
40 years
and i keep going back to it
why can't i put that book back on the
shelf and leave it there the way i've
done with all these other books because
there's still questions
unanswered for me in that book this is
coming from somebody
who was a professor of classics
who had spent
think about how many hours he'd spent on
the symposium alone let alone the rest
of plato's works and there were still
questions in it
sometimes there were new questions
sometimes they're old questions
that remained open
this is the sort of thing that gets
people to investigate not only things in
books
but in history in
uh all sorts of other venues
they become captivated by what those
authors have to communicate to them
so
great philosophical works
when we read them attentively
and i would say actually generously
generously
with your time generously with your
effort
generously
with
who you are
uh not just stingily you know giving
plato the half hour that you think it'll
it'll take to get him down to skim it
before class but actually you know
sitting down and reading it
treating it as you would a conversation
with a friend
you're not going to give your friend
less time than the conversation actually
requires are you i mean you're not a
very good friend if you do and you won't
have a lot of friends for very long if
you do but there's a reason why because
your friends are not going to get much
out of it and you're not going to get
much out of it either if all of your
conversations are are oriented just by
well i'm going to give you 20 minutes
here i'm going to give you half an hour
here
if you're in a position to study
great books
each one of them is like
a little microcosm
you can get so much out of it that it's
worth
opening up for yourself
the time that it requires
in order to have that conversation with
the author of the book or you know not
only with the author of the book but all
the other people
whose voices are in that book if you're
reading plato's dialogues socrates is is
one voice
usually you know we think representing
plato
and it might be thrasymachus or it might
be calloclees or it might be gorgeous
and it might be some of his friends and
there might be you know five or six
different perspectives being uh bandied
about there
and that conversation
is if you
work with it if you invest the time
and you invest the effort
in the right ways
then you'll find it more and more and
more rewarding at first you may find it
actually very difficult
you may get frustrated
it's sort of like
beginning exercise you know when you
begin lifting weights the next day
you're really sore
and the best thing to do though is
actually what to take it easy
and just lay around watch tv no it's
actually to get back in there and use
those muscles again and bring blood back
into them and limber them back up and
that's the same thing with with with
reading
so here's the thing i'd like you to take
away from this your guiding assumption
ought to be anytime that you approach a
classic philosophical work
there's a lot here
that's worthwhile if i put in the effort
if i don't put in the effort i'm never
going to see it
i can buy cliffs notes i can buy plato
for dummies and i can get some content
that way but that's not the same thing
as as
experiencing the effect of a great work
of literature so now we have to think
about what kind of efforts this is the
second thing
i'm going to talk about
and some of this seems kind of common
sensical
if you want to understand what's going
on within a philosophical text
you have to read it and then read it and
reread and reread and you keep on coming
back to it but i think of it
not so much like a repetitive process of
just you know read this time read this
time read this time read this time read
this time
think of it more as a process of back
and forth of conversation
if you're reading a text closely
the first time that you read it
there you go first time that you read it
you're over here right and the text is
is way over here and you're sort of
looking at each other
from from a distance and you skim
through it and you get it done and and
maybe you catch a lot of what's going on
in there or maybe you don't and then you
read it again and you start to get a
little bit closer
and you read it again and you start to
get a little bit closer and now you find
yourself actually
in dialogue there's those are talking
hands right in dialogue
with the the author of the text why do
you think this
uh what you're saying over here actually
seems to imply that this over here can't
be right
but
maybe it is i have to think about this
more what you're saying here
that
informs what you're saying over here
doesn't it these are the sort of
questions you want to ask
yourself but also ask the author of the
text as you're reading it through
um if you're taking a class what i
suggest is that you read the text
several times before class
and then make sure
to read some of the sections of the text
after the class sessions that you you
discuss those those uh
those concepts those passages
because you're going to get so much more
out of it i it's the same thing if
you're going to say a great books club
you know a lot of libraries have great
books clubs if you want to participate
in them it's not very difficult
read your text and then you come to the
club and then you know you have
discussion with other people and maybe
somebody leads it
and then you come back to the text
afterwards and you find that you've
gained something in the process
so here's what i would actually suggest
doing
if you want to study classic texts
whether you're doing it just on your own
or whether you're doing it as a student
in the class
read through the text
just once
to see what's going on
you know think about how to read it you
know what sort of genre it is but but
read it get get through it
if you don't understand something keep
on going plow through it
then come back to it and now read it a
little bit more
leisurely
lingering over the parts lingering over
two kinds of parts
lingering over the parts that you really
enjoy
and you'll you'll really enjoy them
probably for two
main reasons one will be because you get
it
because you or you think you get it
uh sometimes you you think you get it
and then later on you realize you don't
and i've had that experience many times
myself but you you read through it and
linger over the parts that you enjoy
um it may be because you get it or it
may be because you just really like the
style or what's going on in that passage
you know
maybe you like watching socrates thrash
thrasymachus
verbally in argument maybe you get a
kick out of that that's great
use that pleasure use that desire use
that to keep you in the text the other
passages to linger over are the ones
that you don't get where you're at a
loss you're saying what the hell is
going on here i don't even know what
he's talking about
linger over
them think about them
that doesn't mean that you have to stay
there with those but do take a note of
them
mark them
put a question mark next to them
you'll come back to it do it in pencil
too by the way because you're gonna
what you think about the text is going
to change over time
then you know if you've been given
discussion questions read through the
text again and and try to answer those
discussion questions as you go along
take notes
at least one of the times that you're
reading the text you ought to be taking
notes
on what you think is going on or what
you think the main points are
if you think that something is wrong
put that in the margin this can't be
right
you'll come back to it later on
hopefully
then if you have you know again if you
have a class session
bring up those things in class if you if
you have the opportunity to
professors
at least they should
but many professors do love to have
students who want to talk in class who
want to know about this stuff they don't
need students who know everything inside
and out if they did
have that student teach the class right
what they need are students who are
genuinely interested in the subjects and
are reading attentively and want to know
what's going on with this why is
socrates saying this why is nietzsche
saying this is this right how can this
be possibly be right
another thing that i suggest doing in
addition to reading the text after
whatever class session or you know
discussion you have
is coming back to the text
later you know if you're doing a
semester class
later in the semester read it not just
to refresh your memory you know before a
test or something like that
read it to see if bringing new eyes that
are now informed by the rest of the
things that you're studying
changes your your perspective
i think you probably will find that it
does
sometimes you're just re-familiarizing
yourself with important themes sometimes
you're actually deepening your knowledge
sometimes you're integrating things
you're connecting them together
sometimes you're actually going back to
the same places what you think are the
same places
and they turn out to look very different
just like in a landscape you know if you
have if you're an outdoorsy kind of
person and you like going on trails or
through woods or to to any place really
actually even within the city it's like
this with the seasons
with the change of the light from time
of day
with weather with people being there and
people not being there you look at the
same things very different different
ways
the same
the same
things may show you different faces that
you didn't see before it's the same way
with texts
a passage that you brushed over before
and thought was not all that important
or you thought had only one surface
level meaning may turn out to have a
deeper meaning
may turn out to be connected to some
other things that you hadn't thought
about before
um one of the one of the other things
that i'd like to say about this sort of
nuts and bolts of reading philosophical
texts
there's a couple
questions that i think that you should
pose to yourself and actually not a
couple several questions
and um i think that you can ask yourself
these with just about any text that's
going on
anything that's going on in any text you
can ask yourself these what's being said
you should ask yourself that over and
over again
you know when you get to the end of a
paragraph you should ask yourself do i
did i just run my eyes
over this and i have no idea what's
actually being said can i can i
summarize it can i um
say how i would would explain it to
another person what's being said what's
actually being claimed what's being
asserted
um
another important thing who is being
reported as saying it a lot of
philosophical texts are complex in the
way that they're put together
they may involve something like a
dialogue but not be set up like a
dialogue
so for instance when you're reading
aristotle aristotle has many many
passages where he says
so and so says this
now let's think about this or so and so
says this and he's wrong
in this respect and right in this
respect or the many say this or people
in sparta say this or
those are not aristotle's own views
unless he actually comes out and says
and i think they're right about this
they're
they're they're actually
not his own views
why are they in there well
a lot of the time what we're doing in
philosophy is not just putting forth our
own perspective
we're tying it in with with the
perspectives that many other people have
and share and communicate
and debate about and also put forth as
the right way to think about things
so when you're looking at a
philosophical text
not only ask yourself what's being said
ask yourself who's saying it is the is
it the author of the text or is the
author putting these words in somebody
else's mouth is the author saying these
things to endorse them is the author
saying these things to reject them
to partially
accept them but also criticize them to
take them further to use them as a
starting point
those are all important concerns
then you want to ask yourself
why is
what's been said
why has it been said
and you're going to find clues within
the text
this is one of the things that's
particularly germane to philosophy
it's not just people making a bunch of
claims throwing them out there and
saying there you go
take them or leave them
what they do is they make claims and
then they say this claim
is probably right or it's necessarily
right or you know you must think this
way because
and then they give you some sort of
argument
or
sometimes they give you an explanation
they give you some sorts of reasons
actually they may give you many
arguments you know if you think about
for example thomas aquinas the way that
his works are set up
there are many arguments given
and he'll accept some of them and reject
some of them and when he rejects an
argument he'll say
here's what's wrong with this argument
again that's giving an explanation
this this this isn't right this claim
isn't right and this argument doesn't
work because of that so you ought to be
attentive to those sorts of features
um so we've got
what's being said
who said it
and then why is it being said
and then
if you want to go beyond that
this is placing yourself in dialogue
with the work
i think that it's very useful to ask
yourself at certain points in the work
what else could have been said but
wasn't said
i'll give you one example
when socrates debates with some of his
interlocutors in plato's dialogues
he will make arguments
some of the arguments are are pretty
good
pretty convincing
some of the arguments are actually
pretty bad
they work on his interlocutors
because his interlocutors are are
sometimes not that good at
detecting errors in reasoning or
thinking of counter examples
or you know
just thinking well on their feet and
trying to respond to him
sometimes they they're sort of stuck in
their way of thinking and they haven't
thought about anything else and then he
demolishes one point of it but he does
so in kind of a
sketchy way
and then they said oh god i i i guess my
whole you know set of ideas doesn't work
my whole doctrine falls apart
sometimes it doesn't
and if you're an attentive reader
you could ask yourself hey wait a second
what if somebody had said this at that
point and now you start thinking along
with the philosopher there's you
what if somebody else had said this at
this point and then there's say plato or
nietzsche or kierkegaard or descartes
and they say
if you make them say it
well what i could have said was this
where are you going to get that from
well that's where
reading and re-reading starts to pay off
because
in order to figure out how another
philosopher would respond to your own
criticisms of them
you have to know
you know at least some of their work you
have to know some of their ideas you
have to know you have to have thought
alongside with them long enough
for you to have some sense
of how they would respond
that's all nuts and bolts so that that's
all very good i'm going to talk now
about the larger context
that you can
find yourself in that i think will
enrich your your reading
you want to try to make connections
between texts and maybe if you're in a
class that's easy to do because you're
reading a lot of different texts that
all have to tie in with the same thing
if you're reading
ethics texts
you're you're tying them across
different moral theories and how they
would apply and you know what socrates
might have to say to a manual kant or
vice versa right
um
try to
make connections like that to the other
things that you've read and try to do
that within an author's corpus within
their body of work
there's also another thing i think that
can really be helpful
and
this stems in part from
something that's been going on for a
while in our educational establishment
which is that we don't really teach
history
that well
uh in in many cases so a lot of people
have sort of just a kind of hazy view of
where these philosophical texts fit in
plato's in ancient greece somewhere and
they wore togas and all that
check out the historical context there
are there are many resources for this
available and if you do that
you will find that it really enriches
your understanding of the philosopher
sometimes these philosophers are
actually contributors to history
you know
they are helping to form history not
necessarily right at the start but their
their works may assume some great
importance that way or they may steer
people's mindsets they may open up new
ways of thinking
but you know a lot of the times the
philosophers are actually
responding to the historical context
that they're in the problems of the time
the
issues
the
sorts of things that people had on their
mind that they were talking about
if you understand their historical
context you also understand
what they took for granted
and why they might have said some of the
things that they said you know for
example aristotle defends a certain kind
of slavery
in his his politics
and his his ethics are really
assuming that they're they're written
for free people largely you know men
in greek society
how can his ethics be applicable to to
the rest of us
well you know
if you understand the historical context
you can also understand that if
aristotle were around today he probably
would
widen
the scope of of his ethics
and which is what we actually do when we
try to apply it
another thing with with context
is conversation
it's very helpful to look at what we
call secondary sources which is what
other people have written about these
great books you know many of them have
introductions that you know
are usually pretty good uh read the
introduction you know don't take it as
gospel truth it's the interpretation of
a scholar maybe a very influential
scholar but but you know the
interpretation of somebody who's been
looking at it and you'll find somebody
else if you look you know widely enough
who thinks very differently about that
text or that thinker or those doctrines
or those arguments
but it's worth looking at that because
how do we learn we learn in conversation
with each other and this applies even
for us professional philosophers
when we were in graduate school and we
were doing research we had to learn how
to read secondary text and incorporate
those into
our own thought and now if if we're
still active in our fields professional
philosophers
we read each other's
interpretations
arguments uh articles conference
proceedings all these sorts of things
we we look into those and that's part of
the conversation that we
we have about plato about aristotle
about anselm about hegel about any of
these great important philosophers
so if it's beneficial for us
professional philosophers to do that
it's going to be doubly beneficial
provided you don't you don't try to you
know bite off too much with this
it'll be doubly beneficial for you as a
student
reading these texts perhaps for the you
know first or tenth or twentieth time to
read what some other scholars uh people
who've been devoting their life to
understanding these texts had to say
about them you enter into a conversation
that way another thing i'd like to point
out about this this whole notion of
conversation
is that if you look at the history of
philosophy
what you find are that a lot of these
classic texts themselves
contain
discussions between philosophers and
engage previous philosophers
so you'll find for example
nietzsche very critically engaging plato
and socrates you know complaining about
them quite a bit
but you'll find him taking a stance on
that you find kierkegaard also
in
certain texts talking quite a bit about
plato and irony and i know i've learned
quite a bit
about how to read platonic dialogues by
reading kierkegaard doesn't mean that i
accepted everything that kierkegaard had
to say
but his thought
really spurred a lot of my own thinking
about that about what irony means and
about how to read a dialogue and why why
socrates might be making an argument
that's not quite so good at this point
with another person
so if you read other philosophers
and what they have to say about
the philosopher and the text that you're
trying to make sense out of this is not
something so much for
a class but part of your lifelong
learning you'll find yourself
very much enriched
in the process by
what you get out of this other great
mind talking about the the classic text
that you're looking at
so that's that's something we're
thinking about the last thing that i
want to say
is like i said before a kind of caution
but also a kind of encouragement
and
it has to do with not allowing the best
to become the enemy of the good when
you're reading a classic text
you're gaining something
by their very nature they're rich
they're complex they have many different
layers they don't yield up all of their
secrets their mysteries their
their you know riches their even their
pleasures
to you
at first glance or perhaps even on the
20th reading or on the 100th reading
there's always that's what makes them
classics there's always more to get out
of them there's always more that you can
learn
by engaging with them and that's what
makes them worth going back to so don't
feel bad if you don't get everything the
first time around or the next time
around
this is again we're lifelong learning
and the process of reading and
re-reading and conversing with these
these texts and their authors and with
the whole community of of people who do
that comes in
you know there's a sort of perfectionism
that some people
end up falling into when it comes to
these they want to have
they want to know aristotle inside and
out
but you know again think about this may
be helpful think about your own self do
you truly know your own self inside and
out
do you understand every single thing
that you've ever
said or even all the things you've
written in your lifetime
probably not
there are probably things that if you
went back to you would rethink you would
reframe you would connect up with things
that have you know changed over time
with your experience you would
you would see things that you wrote at
one time and say i was right on one
level and wrong on another
well it's like that for a philosophical
text
um
you're not going to get everything
immediately and don't put it upon
yourself that you have to
um
books great books
this is again part of what makes them
great
it's not as if you just assimilate them
they change you in the process of you
reading them oftentimes without you
really realizing how they're changing
you
and that's a gradual step-by-step
process it's very unpredictable
it's not as if you can create a
guidebook for this sort of thing
but if you do read plato's dialogues if
you do read nietzsche's works if you do
read
saint anselm's works and you really
think about the things that they they're
writing about and you try to
you try to follow them where their their
writings lead
you will find yourself changed
slowly in the process hopefully for the
better
so
what will end up happening is as you do
this your mind will
be more and more um
brought in in sort of a sympathy or a
con naturality with the thing that
you're you're studying you'll find
affinities um that you didn't have
before but but this is not something
that you can
provide a recipe for it's not something
that you can
find shortcuts to you just have to
actually
do it but what i can tell you is it does
happen it's there
and
many people who've been reading these
texts can can tell you about that same
experience so there's something to look
forward to
the last thing about this is
whatever you actually get out of these
texts
that is a good
truth is a good knowledge is a good
any of those sorts of things are goods
they may be limited goods
but they're not valueless
so whatever you happen to take away from
the text
whatever depth you happen to attain
that's something worthwhile